vous souvenez-vous de cette vidéo que
j'ai fait il ya trois ans et qui
s'appelait quand j'étais petit et nos
sens c'était une vidéo dans laquelle je
regardais les photos de moi plus jeune
quand j'avais entre 6 et 12 ans
d'ailleurs très drôle parce que
maintenant si tu regarde cette vidéo tu
te rends compte qu'à l'est au moment où
j'avais fait des vidéos j'étais petit en
fabio devant déçu si pour x raisons j'ai
récemment demandé à mon père de me re
partager le dossier qui contenait toutes
ces photos et je me suis aperçu que
dedans il y avait des vidéos que je
n'avais pas vu à l'époque choix qui
n'était pas dans le dossier vrai à
l'époque des vidéos de moi quand j'avais
7 ans ou 8 ans avec mon énorme tête à
claques et mame et mess la même coupe de
cheveux que maintenant c'est bien
évidemment mon frère m'a aussi prendre
cher parce qu'il sera forcément dans ces
vidéos florent charge m'excuse vraiment
désolé voilà enfin tu m'as démonter à
tekken l'asthmatique vengeance ok ok
première vidéo c'est parti
ça fait un peu plus ouvrir ce début de
vidéo ça fait un peu un mec qui
regardent enfant de 8 ans nager en slip
de bain c'est très bizarre
bon la deuxième la deuxième elle sera
peut-être mieux j'espère pervez [ __ ]
mais c'est ce qui fait déjà à l'époque
c'est incroyable non mais que je veux
vraiment être le pire gamins pour ça je
pense qu' aucun autre gamin n'a fait
autant de fois peur à ses parents en
faisant des cascades dégueulasse trois
ans de gymnastique je rappelle à mon
actif un bon donc voilà forcément après
on développe des petits ce qu'ils on est
un peu agile hockey ensuite à situation
différente pour laquelle ce que c'est
que ça en fait ça c'est florent
charsadda il aurait préféré que je gagne
à tekken éviter ce supplice à florent
avec ma belle mère aime et floraux et
mon frère c'est un petit caïd en
réfutant je me souvenais pas c'est quoi
on a eu la même voie quand muet c'était
amusant bon suivant 3 2 à sa tourne
c'est la voix de mon frère les amis
c'est la voix de ce mec là encore une
valeur sûre gro sans ça le sens très
large choix de personnages et c'est
bizarre parce que quand j'avais son âge
parle exactement de cette manière là
aussi hyper étrange de copé c'est quoi
ça bon alors ça tourne mon père c'est
lui casse les couilles la vôtre bonbons
de chine ont tiré - c'est trop bizarre
est ce que je vais arriver sur la vidéo
ça je me demande si c'est tellement
drôle
la dégustation se fait pour que ce
spécimen sénergues humaines par exemple
manger un bout de taureaux sauvages
il va devenir mais que j'ai envie de me
gifler mais j'avais vraiment la pire
tête à claques de france c'est un truc
de malade j'ai envie de mettre des
claques et de me couper la mâchoire
remise en contexte c'était en vacances
avec mon père ma belle mère
j'avais huit heures je vois un truc
comme ça et j'étais la plus grande des
tags de france 1 on va pas se mentir
j'ai apprécié comme un an les bonnes
choses à savoir la charcuterie le bon
saucisson des familles au soleil on
connaît bien mes mecs jeu il reste
humide de vidéos j'ai lâché mon âme est
en train de mourir dans cette vidéo
vraiment regarder combien la grèce la
pauvre petite croix inoffensif et sans
défense heureusement qu'il ne m'a pas
encore vu
suite appuyé dans les buissons elle se
rappelle tf1 de l'émission late est
juste de bonnes wahou merci le clochard
pour cette intervention d'un enfant de 8
ans incroyable ouais qu'est ce qu'on
vient de voir qu'est ce que vient de
voir je vais lui envoyer en photo la bea
fois déjà je lui avais envoyé une photo
dossier elle est incroyable en fait
depuis qu'il m'a battu à tekken mille
fois en vidéo j'ai grave la m
elana fois j'ai envoyé cette photo là
pour manger waouh quel papa j'aurais pas
dit le franchement j'aurais pas dit
mieux la tête que tu fais là je me
retiens de la faire depuis le début de
la vidéo suivante au alors ça alors ça
je m'en souviens très très bien vu que
j'avais parents divorcés je faisais une
année sur deux noël chez ma mère est née
sur de noël chez mon père enfin le soir
de noël en vrai je le faisais chaque
année avec mes deux parents mais avec
l'unss telle aubry soir noël et avec
l'autre c'était le lendemain et cette
année là l'autre en soit c'était j'ai
mon père et mon père mine de rien quand
on était petits on joue énormément au
jeu vidéo avec lui à mario kart et aussi
à mario kart et mario kart aussi et il
avait une ps2 et il avait acheté la
playstation eye toy je crois elle
s'appelait c'était les prémices de la
kinect si vous voulez où c'était le les
premiers jeux il me semble où tu pouvais
bouger dans l'espace et sa détecté dans
le jeu et du coup c'était des jeux de
course allait sauter fallait courir
faille criaient c'était rigolo c'est un
peu comme la wii au final mais en moins
bien foutu et donc là on jouait à ce
truc là et je crois que j'étais l'enfant
le plus ignoble du monde j'arrêtais pas
de crier de gesticuler dans tous les
sens et vous allez voir que ça casse les
couilles à mon frère vraiment il a envie
de me défoncer la gueule
mais les plus géniales avec ma vie
polaire bleu mais que j'ai mis 600
milliards de fois quand j'étais plus
jeune merci maman d'avoir acheté un seul
pull pour huit années vraiment je
m'éclatais vraiment c est l un des plus
beau noël de ma vie vous l'avez ou pas
et si vous l'avez vu il était il était
10 qualité furtif en fait vu que c'était
mal foutu ralala puisque yann et 1,8 à
galérer un peu à capter et du coup je
m'approche et de la caméra pour kim
capte mieux mais du coup il captait
moins bien ce qui est derrière moi et
donc mon frère il arrêtait pas de mettre
son bras devant au moins comme ça de le
reculer comme vous l'avez vu et des fois
je pense même qu un moment il va rage et
malgré son constructeur
voilà et ben voilà dès le début de la
deuxième vidéo celle insultes qui est
sorti la part de florange a jeté un oeil
en fait c'est donne comme dans nos
souvenirs il même ma belle famille et tu
oublies à l'époque qu'ils avaient cette
gueule en fait j'ai l'impression que mon
frère a toujours eu la gueule qu'il a
maintenant je me souvenais pas du tout
de lui avec la voix qui lui même c'est à
tuer sa mère de parler complètement
différente c'est hyper marrant j'avais
complètement oublié tout ça c'est moi
flo
[Musique]
mes mecs je suis insupportable au teint
je donne raison à tous ceux qui me
détestent de me détester la ba ouai mais
florence est pas grave c'était perdu la
playstation eye toy en 2002 et ouais mon
pote faut croire qu'à l'époque j'arrive
encore à gagner
pardon pardon florent ne me fera pas
parce que tu es une grosse merde jeu
vidéo déjà déjà à l'époque le gain chat
tu fais le guide touristique les a
surpris un rythme haletant creuse mais
tu pues ok ok quoi d'autre quoi de ta
temps c'est super marrant de voir tout
ça au barça c'est plusieurs années plus
tard je devais avoir 12 ans et c'était
en bretagne on était là en bretagne dans
une
quand on appelle ça un mobile-home un
[ __ ] de mobile homes minuscule infesté
par les moustiques les araignées je me
souviens très bien et on avait fait le
cerf-volant sur la plage donc là ça doit
être une vidéo où je fais du serveur sur
la plage pas la logique génial c'est à
dire les vidéos drôles d'internet mais
de ya dix ans l'été les files à l'époque
oui oui c'était gentil
c'était juste un enfant qui déçus devant
quelque chose et pas besoin qu'un mec se
pète une jambe vénère projet reste du
clic n'y en a plus mais non il ya plus
des photos regarder le trio des au char
à l'époque
vous avez vu ça et je me demande quelle
photo j'avais montré ou pas dans mon dos
en 2014 je me souviens plus je crois pas
que je vais montrer celle là en fait à
l'époque je voulais pas je crois que je
voulais pas trop montrer de photos de
mon père et vu que la façon vous l'avez
vu dans les vidéos du japon je m'en fous
et du coup et on peut voir des petites
photos de nos anniversaires de l'époque
bon après tout ça on avait vu un la
gymnastique on se souvient les trois ans
jimmy lonlas en voici les preuves plus
tard mec
la preuve c'était deux ans ou trois ans
avant la vidéo où je jouais à la
playstation la regarder ce que j'ai
comme pull regarder mon pull n'achetez
pas qu'un pull à vos enfants [ __ ]
c'est frustrant au caire et ce qui est
rigolo surtout c'est que dans ces vidéos
là là on reconnaît derrière le salon de
chez mon père dans lequel j'ai fait mes
premières vidéos tout ça la regarde et
bien vous allez le reconnaître
maintenant je crois que c'était un être
seul chez soi je crois en moi ça qui est
la pire vidéo d'internet 1 et surtout
pas l'avoir s'était alors gardé c'est
ouf
c'est ici qu'on joue à la playstation à
noël sauf que le point de vue c'est
d'ici que c'est rigolo on voit la petite
info nul petite info nul voila les amis
écouter ah ah c'est mon frère
oui ça va bien et je faisais une vidéo
où je regarder des vidéos de nous quand
on était tout petit et les vidéos où je
joue à la playstation eye à noël là tu
te souviennes ça or la mecque
je sais pas mais je vois que tu me
battait déjà tekken est franchement tu
baisse d'un ton direct ce que je propose
c'est de raccrocher parce que
l'humiliation est trop forte et du coup
j'ai eu ma petite vengeance on voit ta
tête quand tu as vraiment 14 en quoi
c'est très drôle
bien sûr bien sûr oui mais les alicias
fin de cette vidéo je vais rien vous a
plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aller
mais comme d'habitude et je trouve ça
important des fois de regarder les
photos comme ça c'est vrai que sur le
moment le pot parents ils prennent des
photos des vidéos et c'est peut-être
chien sur le moment même mois
actuellement ça me fait chier quand ma
mère prend des photos à un anniversaire
ou à noël c'est relou mais en vrai
regardez quand tu les revois dix ans
plus tard ça te fait un truc me
souvenais en plus de chacune des
situations
bon après y'a que trois situations mais
bon je me juste mais quand même des
moments mais voilà l'idée que je me
faisais ce moment là était finalement
différente de la réalité des choses
voilà c'est très beau ce que j'ai à dire
je vous propose de venir sur ça moi je
vais vous fait parce qu'il est midi 8 et
un core sas alimente même le bien même
si vous en doutez [ __ ] je vous dis à
bientôt les amis au revoir ouais quand
je très fort je vais comme ça la plongée
[Musique]